pas
[Musique]
à
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci sans mots simplement avec des
gestes
je viens de partager avec vous onze
mille trois cent vingt-quatre jours de
vie de mes peines de mes joies de mes
réussites mais aussi de mes défaites
d'amour et de haine et confidences pour
confidences à chaque fois que je danse
c'est comme si un pouvoir se déployer
c'est comme si je devenais plus forte et
quelque part un peu plus sage je
m'appelle guen raku de vaud
je suis né en france et je suis malgache
de culture aux antipodes qui se sont
rencontrés comme deux planètes qui se
seraient entre choqué en un seul corps
on parle beaucoup de métissage comme
quelque chose qui est merveilleux
enrichissant génial mais dans la société
dans laquelle on vit ça peut aussi être
un challenge un poids à porter voyez
lorsque j'étais enfant par exemple il
était très difficile pour moi de trouver
ma place dans la société
il n'était pas facile de ne pas
complètement appartenir à l'un et de ne
pas complètement appartenir à l'autre
j'étais un peu perdu un peu comme un
extraterrestre
un peu comme un symbole de mon enfance
un peu comme it is it il savait
d'extraterrestres qui cherchait en
permanence à téléphoner maison sans
jamais y parvenir
alors moi j'ai trouvé mon téléphone tout
comme outil d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé mon
téléphone
la danse la danse est arrivée comme une
rencontre déterminante dans ma vie elle
m'a permis de réconcilier toutes les
choses qu'il y avait à l'intérieur de
moi des différentes cultures mais
différentes cultures
les épreuves de la vie les injustices et
donc aussi toutes les choses que je
porte et que je portais
et à travers le temps j'ai découvert que
dans c'était un pouvoir un pouvoir qui
sommeille en chacun de nous faut un
pouvoir qui serait similaire
enfin je crois c'est mes croyances qui
serait similaire à une graine que l'on
pourrait mettre à l'intérieur qui serait
à l'intérieur et que l'on pourrait
arrosé de telle sorte que la grande
plante de la danse développé de telle
sorte que si je demandais à n'importe
lequel d'entre vous de venir sur scène
et de faire une petite démonstration de
danse vous seriez capable de le faire je
sais que c'est ce que vous pensez oh non
non non non pas moi moi je ne sais pas
danser
moi je ne sais pas mettre un pied devant
l'autre et j'ai encore moins le rythme
dans la peau
si l'un d'entre vous à penser ça lever
la main assez bien il ya des gens qui se
connaissent bien
dans la salle eh bien je vais vous
donner un exemple qui est pourrait nous
mettre d'accord
on a tous fait l'expérience d'être dans
une salle avec un enfant en bas âge mis
la musique et vu cet enfant
immédiatement bouger sur le rite s'est
dandinée en rite bien en rythme et bien
j'imagine qu'aujourd'hui si nous sommes
tous des adultes je vois pas d'enfants
dans la salle mais si nous sommes tous
des adultes
c'est qu'à un moment donné dans notre
vie nous avons été un enfant est un
enfant en bas âge et donc il est fort
probable qu'il vous est déjà arrivé
comme je viens de le décrire il ya
quelques secondes être ce petit enfant
en bas âge qui dansaient sur le rythme
j'ai pas vous faire danser tout de suite
alors comment se manifeste le pouvoir de
la danse et bien paradoxalement pour moi
tant que danseuse professionnelle les
plus grands moments de danse ne sont pas
les moments lorsque j'étais sur scène
ces moments sont magiques et unique
certes mais les moments les plus forts
que j'ai vécu son seul lorsque il y à du
partage est un artiste voyez un danseur
une danseuse c'est pas simplement une
étoile qui brille sur scène c'est aussi
un être humain qui se doit diversifier
pour pouvoir vivre et donc il m'arrive
parfois d'être invité pour transmettre
la danse c'est dans ces moments là
dans un contexte qui est à première vue
paraît banal les choses extraordinaires
s'opère c'est par exemple au contact
d'un public de jeunes avec des
déficiences mentales que j'ai découvert
là sous un autre jour
ces jeunes pour la plupart n'ont pas de
troubles physiques mais ils ont
développement mental qui est restreint
et plus lents et donc dans une société
on ne demande tous d'être les mêmes
cela créé un écart entre eux
notre monde et leur monde pardon et donc
on m'a demandé d'intervenir auprès de
ces jeunes pour leur transmettre la
danse pour les initier à l'expression
corporelle à la danse afin de les aider
à oser prendre leur place à l'image des
futurs citoyens qui seront demain et
ceci sur le sur le thème même pas peur
de découvrir d'exister d'être ensemble
j'intervenais donc auprès de ces jeunes
et tout se passait très bien évoluer à
leur rythme tout était très facile et un
jour un grand défi est venu à moi
et c'est appeler la fête de
l'association tous les ans l'institut
médico éducatif qui hack jeunes font une
fête pour que les jeunes puissent
partager ce qu'ils font avec leur
famille et leurs proches et on m'a
demandé bâtir pour cette fête ce serait
bien que tu fasses une chorégraphie une
danse avec tous ces jeunes là je me suis
dit oui ce serait bien mais 45 jeunes
avec une manière singulière de voir le
monde avec une manière singulière de
s'insérer dans et avec la difficulté
aussi de s'accorder à une seule tâche à
la fois le challenge était très haut
mais je me suis dit qu'on allait tenter
qu'on allait essayer de faire quelque
chose et à cette époque je travaillais
sur un autre projet un projet baroque et
j'étais donc familiariser avec la
musique de lully la marche des turcs
alors pour ceux qui connaissent je ne
vais pas la chanter et pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas je ne vais pas la
chanter non plus mais pour vous donner
une idée c'est une ambiance louis xiv
balle très royale alors je me suis dis
pas tiens pourquoi pas tenter lully
pourquoi pas tenter quelque chose qui
rassemblerait c'est ainsi qu'à lundi au
soleil
je me suis retrouvé dans la petite salle
de sport de l'institut médico-éducatif
une semaine avant la fête de la sauce
est fascinant il semaine avant la fête
de l'association
pour commencer cette danse est donc j'ai
demandé au premier groupe que j'avais
s'ils pouvaient me donner départ pour
commencer cette danse et c'est ainsi
qu'on a commencé par saluer puis on a
montré nos belles chaussures
on s'est salué à nouveau on a dessiné un
arc en ciel vers l'arrière puis caressée
l'herbe on a fait un tour sur soi pour
dessiner un soleil et on a tout
recommencé
c'est ainsi que la danse du roi et de la
reine est née et on s'est dit que pour
cette danse on se tiendrait bien droit
et qu'on serait bien fier pour le créer
partager par dont la création que nous
avions créé le jour de la fête de
l'association est arrivé très vite
et lorsque je suis rentré dans la cour
de l'institut médico-éducatif j'ai pris
tout de suite peur j'ai eu très peur
d'un côté il y avait les l'atelier
maquillage le stand de chamboule tout il
y avait même un karaoké l'ambiance était
assurée alors les jeunes s'amuser et je
me suis dit mais qu'est ce qu'il va
devenir de notre danse sérieuse du roi
et de la reine est ce que les jeunes
vont répondre présents
hélas la musique le temps de la danse
est arrivé la musique de lullier a
retenti les jeunes sont arrivés avec des
membres de leur famille qu'ils
connaissaient pas la danse ils se sont
réunis
on s'est mis en cercle et là c'est comme
si le temps s'était arrêté
nous nous sommes tenus la main nous
avons dansé nous avons ri et nous avons
dansé encore et nous avons ré et les
actions autour de nous ont cessé tout
devenait calme
ainsi le temps les pendant les trois
minutes de la marge de lully les jeunes
ont existé avec leur différence certes
mais nous étions tous à l'unisson la
musique s'est arrêté et nous étions en
délire
le temps d'une danse ces jeunes ont eu
peur de découvrir d'exister ni eu peur
d'être ensemble et c'est ça le pouvoir
de la danse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]